Mit einer knusprigen Panade lassen sich
teure zutaten lukrativ strecken.
Sebastian Lege prüft, welche Markenhersteller besonders gerne an Fisch, Fleisch und Käse sparen,
und zeigt wo das
Profi-Paniermehl eigentlich herkommt.
Die Spur der Industriepanade für
Sebastian ins Rheinland nach Neuss.
In dieser Anlage wird ein Spezialbrot
gebacken, das niemals beim Bäcker landet.
Jede menge Teig wird hier produziert,
denn Profi-Paniermehl wird nicht wie zu
hause aus altem Brot oder Brötchen
gemacht.
SEBASTIAN: "Eine Brotschanze!"
Mit über 3.000 Tonnen Paniermehl im Monat ist die Firma Brata, Europas größter Hersteller.
Drin stecken einfache Zutaten:
Mehl, Wasser, Salz und Hefe.
Nach dem Backen wird das Brot maschinell zerteilt.
WIESENDAHL: "Ja, das ist heiß!"
SEBASTIAN: "Aber riecht richtig gut!"
Doch es kommt nicht nur auf den Geschmack
an, wichtig ist auch die Farbe des Bröselbrotes.
Dafür sorgt hier ein exotisches Gewürz.
WIESENDAHL: "Hier haben wir jetzt Kurkuma. Das ist dafür da, dass der Teig nachher gelb wird."
SEBASTIAN: "Und später dann die Schnitzel richtig schön golden, oder?"
WIESENDAHL: "Genau!"
Kurkuma - auch Gelbwurz genannt - stammt aus Südasien.
Zu Pulver gemahlen sorgt sie für eine kräftige Farbe - ideal für die goldbraune Optik.
Weiteres Plus: Panierte Schnitzel etwa bleiben beim Braten saftiger als unpanierte.
Durch die einfachen Zutaten und schnelle
Herstellung ist Paniermehl ein sehr günstiges Produkt.
Die ideale Zutat für Trickser!
SEBASTIAN: "Schön gelb wird schön gold."
WIESENDAHL: "Und frischer geht's nicht!"
SEBASTIAN: "Das frischste alte Brot, das man haben kann."
WIESENDAHL: "Genau! Gerade zwei Stunden alt."
Doch welche neuen Produkte mit
Paniermehl lassen sich noch entwickeln?
Eine Frage, der Markus Wiesendahl in
seinem Testlabor nachgeht.
Hier tüftelt er an Rezepten für die Industrie.
Sebastian Lege hat da eine Idee.
SEBASTIAN: "Ich habe heute mal eine kleine Challenge mitgebracht."
WIESENDAHL: "Sauergurken?!" - "Genau!"
Ein neuer profitabler Knuspersnack?
Das Problem: Ähnlich wie Calamari-Ringe haben Gurken eine feste, glatte Oberfläche.
Paniermehl bleibt da schlecht haften.
Damit es trotzdem klappt, setzt Markus
Wesendahl auf eine Geheimwaffe namens Nasspanade.
WIESENDAHL: "Da haben wir spezielle Mehle und Stärken drin, aber die Details kann ich natürlich
dazu nicht verraten."
In Verbindung mit Wasser entsteht aus der Stärkemehlmischung eine Art Klebstoff.
Auf teure Eier, wie wir sie zu Hause nehmen, kann die Industrie so verzichten.
SEBASTIAN: "Was meinst du? Einmal oder zweimal panieren?"
WIESENDAHL: "Doppelt panieren, bei so viel Wasser."
SEBASTIAN: "Doppelt, ne? Ist zu feucht."
Stark wasserhaltige Lebensmittel wie
Sebastians Gurken werden generell
zweimal paniert, denn nur so entsteht ein
knuspriger Mantel um den feuchten Kern -
ohne durchzuweichen!
WIESENDAHL: "Ab ins Fett!"
Jetzt zeigt sich, ob die Panade auch an den glatten, feuchten Gewürzgurken haften bleibt.
SEBASTIAN: "Boah, die sehen richtig gut aus!"
Die Optik stimmt, aber schmeckt der Snack auch wie erhofft?
Nur dann lässt er sich auch vermarkten.
SEBASTIAN: "Das schmeckt!"
"Also, ich würde mal sagen für
acht Stück nehmen wir 3,50 Euro."
WIESENDAHL: "Na dann!"
"Lass und morgen gleich weitermachen!"
SEBASTIAN: "Zack! Die Gürckchen-Millionäre sind geboren."
Sebastians Rechnung ist zwar fiktiv, aber
nicht unrealistisch.
In Amerika sind frittierte Gurken sogar
schon ein Hit.
Die Industrie weiß jedenfalls längst: mit Panade macht man Profit.
Beispiel Camembert: Pur kostet er im Schnitt sechs Euro pro Kilo, paniert zweieinhalb mal soviel: 15 Euro!
Und auch Alaska-Seelachs lässt sich vergolden: Unpaniert liegt das Kilo bei knapp 5 Euro.
Mit Knuspermantel zahlt man mehr als
das Doppelte.
Satte Preisaufschläge für ein bisschen Paniermehl und das bisschen ist manchmal ganz schön viel!
SEBASTIAN: "Dann wollen wir mal gucken, wie viel Panade auf dem Produkt so drauf ist."
Produktentwickler Sebastian Lege beginnt mit dem beliebtesten Stück Fleisch der Deutschen:
dem Schnitzel.
SEBASTIAN: "Was man hier so richtig schön erkennen
kann, bei den industriell parnierten Produkten:
Diese kleinen Rillen hier
sorgen dafür, dass die Panade schön haften bleibt."
"Und in so eine Rille fällt auch immer ein Körnchen mehr von dem guten günstigen Zeug."
Die Fertigschnitzel von Edeka können sich dennoch sehen lassen.
Das Fleisch macht in unserer Stichprobe fast drei Viertel des Produktgewichts aus.
Der Panade-Anteil beträgt 26 Prozent.
Beim Alpenhain Back-Camembert sieht es
schon kritischer aus:
Grob zwei Drittel Käse, ein Drittel Panade.
Und beim Klassiker auf dem Kinderteller?
SEBASTIAN: "Mal sehen was so ein Fischstäbchen mit Panade wiegt."
"29,8 Gramm. Jetzt puhlen wir die Panade ab und sehen mal, wie viel Fisch dann noch übrig bleibt."
Hersteller Frosta verspricht saftiges
Seelachsfilet, knusprig frittiert.
"Na ich würde sagen, noch ein, zwei Krümelchen liegen hier noch an der Seite."
"Aber zwölf Gramm Panade für ein
Fischstäbchen..."
Wiegt man alle Stäbchen, kommt man auf einen Fischanteil von 65 Prozent.
Auch hier also gut zwei Drittel Produkt,
ein drittel Panade.
Doch wie steht es um die Back-Fischstäbchen von iglo mit 100% Filet?
"Ich habe hier 11,5 Gramm Fischfilet. Jetzt legen wir den Backteig mal drauf."
"Ist das der Knaller! 16,7 Gramm Backteig."
Gerade mal 49 Prozent Fischfilet.
Das billige Drumherum macht über die
Hälfte des Gewichts aus.
"Deswegen fällt die Deklaration auch so aus: Backfisch-Stäbchen."
"Da kommt erst der Backteig und dann der Fisch."
Ärgerlich für die Verbraucher, aber völlig legal.
Die Backteig-Version ist sogar teurer als
iglos klassische Fischstäbchen.
Der Trick mit der Panade: für die Industrie ein lohnendes Geschäft.
In unserem Vergleich schneidet das Schnitzel am besten ab. Es enthält am wenigsten Panade.
Backkäse und die meisten Fischprodukte liegen im Mittelfeld.
Backfisch-Stäbchen und Chicken Nuggets sind die Schlusslichter.
Viel Panade, wenig vom wertvollen Inhalt.
SCHAUTZ: "Natürlich können die Hersteller mit einem hohen Anteil an Panade viel Geld sparen,
indem sie weniger von der wertgebenden Zutat einsetzen."
"Hier ist es für den Verbraucher immer
wichtig zu kontrollieren, wie viel
Fleisch, Fisch oder Käse steckt
eigentlich unter meiner Panade,
um dann herauszufinden, welches
Produkt möchte ich kaufen."
Die Hersteller sind verpflichtet, die
Anteile auf der Zutatenliste auszuweisen.
Wer sichergehen will, dem hilft der
Blick auf die Verpackung.
Leckeres "guilty pleasure" oder überteuert und ungesund? Wie steht ihr zu panierten Fertigprodukten?
Schreibt es uns in die Kommentare!
Und wo es die besten Lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt, zeigen wir
euch auf unserem Kanal ZDFbesseresser.